oh and merry christmas
the amazing people over at originpc.com
wanted me to tell you
that if you're looking to get some pc
upgrades
and gear that will bring you holiday
cheer when you purchase select systems
you can get
free for free three-day expedited
shipping
on selected eon laptops only your choice
of
free 50 amazon gift card or
a selected sound blaster x h5
headset our free digital copy of destiny
2
with select systems with qualifying
nvidia gpus
that's all check out originpz.com it's a
great website i'm so excited to finally
get my computer from them as well
and that's it enjoy the video
i have returned
you thought i was gonna give up didn't
you
well think again everybody cuz i'm back
do not ride snake they say i say
whatever whatever so how do i
how do i do this how does it work
i have a feeling i'm gonna be here a
while
oh wow okay you can really launch
yourself
because it's a flexi bucket that's easy
i figured that out with my iq ah my eyes
are burning
all by myself people struggle in this
bit
needs to realize
don't even care watch this
fine fine i know what i must do the
challenge
is easy the mission is hard my penis
bucket for [ __ ] sake man i gotta watch
it stop dangling
now
nope jesus okay we're fine
just gotta wait for it to stop dangling
meanwhile
i will go into my nether realm
channeling my chakra as a great man once
said
[ __ ] are nice people
god damn it
watch this watch this
oh my
oh my god
i am the best player
it's not because i am the best it's
because
i practice in real life irl
apparently you gotta climb up this now
isn't that great
what the [ __ ] is this this is the
slipperiest surface i have ever seen
wow oh
oh oh wow
oh wow this hey guys
nate daddy's working i have the biggest
mouse pad
in my heart it exists
in my heart my mouse pad is so large
it works at nintendo i have the largest
mousepad
just think about how big your mousepad
is
everyone is so impressed by the size of
your mousepad
oh wow a small slip won't matter much as
long as you block out the haters
there won't be anyone left there won't
be anyone left
look at that [ __ ] dog dude you're a
talent
you're a beast
just think about how big your mouse pad
is
it's so big you have the largest mouse
pad
oh oh whoa whoa oh great
oh fantastic why don't we hear him say
some
stupid sh about it huh huh
there's a stupid voice over volume what
do you got to say about that
mr foddy as long as i don't fall down
from here you know what
whatever whatever doesn't matter
one day more
one name of a revolution
what the hell dude i don't understand i
don't i may not understand a lot of
things
but i do understand that we're getting
close
getting close i can smell them why the
heckery dude
like why why what did i do huh what i do
huh
what i do huh did i hurt you did i hurt
you
monday more forever why am i singing
les miserables why
stop sliding if the if everyone stopped
sliding
the world would be a better place you
know who said that
alfonso you know that hey
you know the guy everyone knows an elf
and so
i am out of mouse pad so i'm just going
to drag myself this way
oh god my keyboard is in the way uh
that's fine that's fine let's just uh
redo that
jesus christ you're complaining about
your matchpad page what are you baby
okay so you don't sound like a baby when
you say that okay sure buddy
sure you know who invented the mouse pad
that's right
jesus christ that's why i'm a christian
channel get with the times
stop oh my god what are you made out of
slippery slope come on felix you can do
this
remember your name felix all right i
remember
what the hell dude what the hell dude
that is not the good stop a sliding
have i told you the story about how the
mouse pad was invented
it was in croatia back in 1965
one guy was like man that's slippery
not how that's the story i think you hit
like a sweet spot
in some places cause like is it angling
more and more is what i'm asking
that's all i want to know oh actually
you know we could actually make it up
why do i speak oh oh oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god come on felix
oh oh
i am the one
oh it feels good
okay okay okay okay this is so
nerve-wrecking
oh my god stay there
are you kidding me right thought about
who you are in this
are you the man in the pot diogenes
are you his hand i use the top of his
hammer
okay i think not where your hand moves
how about and you invest
you invest into a pop filter how about
that man's hand
okay unless you're his will his intent
he embodied listen you made a hard game
okay calm down
come down
oh my god
no no no jesus christ hey he did a rhyme
everybody
oh this is ridiculous
oh my god the lag did you see that jesus
christ
i did it i'm almost at the top get out
of my way
my thing you better not [ __ ] launch
me to
some stupid oh
where the hell am i
look at that i'm so good at this game
no you've come shut the f yeah i did the
church
and the rectory i i conquered in the
factory
yes i did playground the construction
site uh okay
rocks listen to the lakeside yes what
else
learn to hike there's no way left to go
but up
where do you think i'll shut up but let
me say
yep i'm glad you came
well that's kind of sweet
don't do that felix don't do that
oh oh my god jesus
christ did you see that the skill
can i grab yes
can i stay on it
damn it
oh i can't bend it it's stuck
oh i guess i can oh my god
oh my god my head is burning up by the
way
it's so hot i'm dying
i will conquer
oh my god you almost just cucked
yourself
jesus christ dude oh i gotta launch i
gotta launch
okay that shouldn't be hard right
whoa what just happened what is
happening
what that can i no oh dedicate this guy
the one who came this far ah i give it
to you with
all of my love am i going back down
again no
no no no don't go back
down
i'm alone
oh i'm [ __ ] myself what is happening
i'm in space
that was easy i did it leave a like
get this to trending if you ever thought
i couldn't do it or if i thought i could
do it
get this to trending this is come on
come on i'm glad i can get rid of this
sledgehammer
that's been in my room for the past
weeks i didn't think i would actually
make the game
there were some parts that was so
difficult that i was like
there's just no way and i just kept
going with this meme like i was gonna
keep going no matter what
but on the i on the other end i was
ready to give up
so many times you have no idea
i mean it's a game like who gives a [ __ ]
but at the same time it was it was fun
to see all you guys uh
interaction with it and like will he
make it or come on you don't give up
keep going and all that [ __ ] so
it's cool i really i had a lot of fun
playing this game thanks to bennett
foddy
for making such a unique and uh
incredible game and that's it for me
goodbye
brofist